we have this story from CNN business
this is great from last Friday
Starbucks workers at 150 stores go on
strike over Pride decorations that's
right ladies and gentlemen they said
that there was no policy to take down
Pride decorations and then 150 United
Starbucks stores in the United States
went on strike on Friday I think I said
about 3 500 employees will be on strike
and I believe we have from the
post-millennial
Starbucks Union boasts they closed 21
locations last weekend in response to
the alleged lgbtq Pride decoration ban
I think it's fair to say it's not
alleged the workers at these stores said
they weren't allowed to put up
decorations I don't care what corporate
is saying the people are that they're
actually protesting here's what I think
Evan I think Starbucks said outright
we're going to lose a bunch of money
shut it down and the workers protested
I think that what we're seeing now is as
I mentioned earlier in the show the Bud
Light effect shows
get will go broke but also anti-woke
equals clicks and so you're seeing a lot
of apolitical people now coming out and
being like Oh yeah I don't like Bud
Light because they know they're going to
get a million hits if they do it
Starbucks was just like we better get
out of this one just take it down and
now their employees are revolting
well they're they're employees are in
Revolt that's absolutely revolting yeah
it is funny how that word goes into two
directions no there's their employees
are in Revolt at many locations because
this is what happens big corporations
know
look
we're gonna we're in the members only
section we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna play the video of the guy
doing something in front of Jojo like I
got to be very careful I didn't want to
explain it spreading himself and you
know it's it's it's a horrifying in
public and I I would normally like to
challenge YouTube and be like hey
YouTube Here's a video from pride in
public with children certainly you can't
have a problem with that right but I I
know that there's a line we've we did it
before with one video because I'm like I
don't think YouTube would take this down
they didn't this one I'm like they're
gonna take it down there's there's
videos of explicit nudity and it's it's
like with these books like genderqueer
when parents tried to rate it to the
school board meeting they get banned
from it but the kids are reading it so
you know anyway my point is we'll show
that in the members only section but I
think what's happening is when you see
an old man uh when you see a guy in a
diaper and a dog mask running up to your
kids turning around and wiggling his
butt at them parents are starting to go
like hey hold on there a minute when you
get the video of the guy with the Bugs
Bunny mask fully nude and then jumping
up and down and shaking his his genitals
in front of in front of people and their
kids at this event
regular people go yo hold on there a
minute then Starbucks comes out and says
we love it and they go I ain't going to
Starbucks anymore Bud Light is the
perfect example of it Smackdown no
longer the top here in the country and
all these corporations fear it
it's the hubris right it's the pride
like they think they can get away with
acting in a revolting manner right like
this is actually disgusting Behavior
that's repulsive to normal everyday
people even it's even repulsive to
people that are part of the LGBT
community I I that's why it's fracture
that's why you're getting it's
fracturing groups like gays against
groomers and all that and then get the L
Out quote get the L out and quote is the
name of an organization it's uh lesbians
who don't want to be associated with
what's going on I love it but yeah we
need to see more of that it's it they're
they're dividing all of our factions and
now that it's coming home to roost and
but they can't there's going to be
continued it's going to continue to get
more and more extreme and there will be
more pushbacks like this is going to
hurt Starbucks I don't know how long I
don't know how badly it's not going to
be the target problem but I I don't get
it I mean Starbucks is a pretty gay
friendly company uh the idea that
they're not gay enough is kind of a
weird argument I don't think any of
these companies care
you know people talk about ESG and CEI
or whatever and I'm like they just want
look when there was no pushback
companies were like how much will it
cost to do a pride month thing it'll
cost five grand for the decorations and
what's our upside oh we'll be involved
in this big celebration and then we'll
maybe see a bump in sales now there's
pushback now they say yeah it'll cost
you five grand to do and you'll lose
three hundred thousand dollars per
location because people will boycott
your store and they're like pull the
decorations they don't actually care
it's all about the path of least
resistance and the fact that regular
people are providing resistance these
companies are immediately just changing
course
the regular people thing matters a lot
like I said uh I mean I've said this
before on the show I was just in
California doing some more ATR stuff
last couple weeks and some of my friends
out there like you talk to him about
this stuff and and they're like look I
got kids and I'm a progressive guy and
stuff but man that ain't right but I
don't want to do this and they really
understood the the ramifications of
having you know their kids be exposed to
this stuff and I think that the average
person is is rejecting it out of hand I
think that the normal people that are
again you know have maybe 15 20 minutes
a week for politics that's all they
spend on on knowing what's going on in
the world you know they they maybe they
see some memes that their friends send
and then they'll listen to you know the
news for 15 minutes the in the evening
or whatever or in the morning those
people are the ones that are like yo I
don't like the idea of the teacher
wanting my child to transition
you know I watched The Passion of the
Christ for the first time
wow I heard it's gruesome it is it's
really and um
the beginning I thought was a little
slow and then it actually got really
really good it's not uh I wouldn't
describe it as explicitly religious I
mean obviously it is but what I mean is
it's political and now the reason I
bring this up is someone's just to
mentioned because of all this there's
going to be a far right backlash and
then I saw that I thought to myself I'm
like well I did just watch the passion
for the first time ever because I was I
was curious I'm like you know I grew up
Catholic not Christian not real but I do
now want to understand more so what the
points that are being made so I did
watch it and uh it was it was it's it's
it's it's actually pretty good I do
think you know
there needs to be a movie for the
average person this one was in Aramaic
Hebrew and Latin the subtitles hard to
watch but the reason I bring it up is I
learned a lot that I didn't know even
having gone to Catholic School
that changed my perspective on some of
these issues
and I think part it is partly due to
what we are seeing from the left that I
was open to having watched a movie like
that again I'm not a Christian I do
believe in God I don't believe in the
Christian like the Catholic church or
anything like that
but it got me watching this and learning
about Pontius Pilate and um what was the
name at the murderer who was released
and all this stuff Barabbas and all this
stuff things I didn't know that you know
the Pontius was like I can release one
person Jesus or Barabbas the murderer
and they're like release the murderer
like that's how much they hate him see
you went to Catholic school and they
didn't cover this nope that is
incredible but that may be why there's a
break in relationship
they said they filled the crowd with
people that were like get Jesus I think
they had false Flags I think they had
like yeah that's right I don't want to
talk I'm not trying to bring stuff so we
can talk about religion my point was
simply
I do believe there will be a pendulum
swing towards the right because of this
I think what's happening now is people
are starting to ask questions of how to
get to the point where there are
pedophiles shaking their genitals in
front of children and thrusting and you
know towards them while they watch and
it's like well I don't think it's it
completely correlates with with religion
but the pendulum will swing people will
look back at where we were 10 years ago
and say what were we doing back then
it's like oh okay we had standards the
standards were like this you're going to
hear arguments from people who are
Christian who are Catholic and they're
going to say here's what we believe and
why we oppose it and then you're going
to get regular moms and dads who are
like what do I have to do to stop the
man from gyrating nude in front of my
children and the left is going to say
you're a bigot and the right is going to
say church is this way there's already
people that are starting to talk about
you know Christian nationalism and stuff
and that's the the too far swing back to
the right and like people like James
Lindsay thankfully are already like
looking for ways to push back against it
because there is going to be an a
reaction from the right there's way more
people going to church now than there
were probably five years ago there's way
more young people converting or
rediscovering religion in response to
what they're seeing as what they would
consider uh perversion or whatever or
what is it what's the word they like to
use deviancy or whatever
um but it's something that liberals and
again normal liberals not
progressives it's something that
liberals have to be aware of and have to
be be concerned with because you don't
want to allow the government to have too
much influence by the Christian right
like
a liberal Society can make room for the
Christian right it can make room for
progressives it can make room for for
Muslims it can make room for everybody
if you have a liberal society that
doesn't favor one ideology right now our
liberal Society is heavily influenced
and heavily favors Progressive ideology
and we I think it's really important to
not allow the pendulum to swing back and
I know if Sheamus were here he'd be
screaming at me but I really do think
that it's important to not let the
pendulum swing back too far so make a
little bit yes definitely back well you
know to the point where we're not like
genitals off of little kids isn't that
funny though that it was the kids like
they couldn't avoid going the kids route
because that's I think where it all
shifted was when the American people saw
just how much was aimed at our kids
there's two right in schools and and on
TV and and just all of the stuff the
surgeries all that stuff the kids were
the final straw it started kind of with
the women's sports issue right that was
released first started to see a big
pushback they had to go for the kids
yeah because as we've talked about quite
a bit the the birth rates among those of
the liberal worldview are substantially
lower than those of conservatives and so
the saying goes socialists don't have
kids they have yours but it's not
working
the parental rights and education stuff
the reason why Emma had to defend a
genderqueer and this book is gay is
because the left needs to indoctrinate
kids and break them from their families
grooming is one way to do it they they
here's what happens they need to create
a riff between parents and kids to such
a degree that the kids run away from
home it really is a crazy thing right so
I'll give you an example
one of the things we talked about on the
culture War podcast was desistance rates
if a child is gender dysphoric
desistance is when they stop being
dysphoric and there have been a couple
studies that we've cited these are the
cited studies as it pertains to
resistance 61 to 95 or is it 98 uh I
think it's like 96 or it's it's around
there it's in the Heights 90 so let's
say the lowest number 61 to 61 percent
of children suffering gender dysphoria
who receive no intervention desist
that is the majority if we're trying to
do the max amount of good taking a
utilitarian perspective well then we
would lean towards not intervening and
giving medical treatment or sex changes
to kids
she advocated for it despite the fact it
would result in more suicide and more
depression why it's the only way they
can get new recruits to their cult
if children are raised by conservative
parents and conservative households and
conservative communities those kids will
be conservative they need to find a way
to rip those kids from the parents and
they found a way
so if you look at this way
if 61 percent of kids desist
with no intervention and they go on to
lead normal lives
that would mean the suicidal ideation
drops dramatically with no intervention
if you intervene
they say that detransition is almost
non-existent among those that are put on
puberty blockers however going from the
natural rates of desistence and looking
at the percentage of trans people who
who commit suicide which is which is sad
and horrifying we don't want that to
happen
if they take if they take 10 kids
who are gender dysphoric and on the high
end nine out of ten will desist
that means they are taking nine kids and
increasing the risk of suicide among
those kids by something like 50 percent
if they do nothing those nine kids will
not see an increased suicide rate
because there's an increased suicide
rate amongst people who are gender
dysphoric
so when they advocate for giving
intervention to kids who would otherwise
be better they are advocating for
increasing the risk to Suicide that's
why my view is we should not be doing
this I don't care what the AMA says or
whatever but again the point is it
doesn't matter to them because they need
to find a way to rip kids from their
families both Stalin and Hitler made
comments about if you get control of the
children it doesn't matter what the
parents think it's something that is
baked into socialist ideology because
they want because they want to change
society they don't like the liberal
society that we live in and unhappy
people be can be made into
revolutionaries happy people that have
happy families they are not looking to
revolt so the left the Revolutionary
left unquestionably wants miserable
people with destroyed lives so that way
they can make them into activists happy
people don't Revolt you're not going to
get a revolution when most people are
happy that's the biggest problem that
Herbert Marquis found with with
capitalism he re he was like look
capitalism delivers the goods so we have
to find other unhappy people because
capitalism has made the proletariat
mostly happy mostly successful they have
a good life Sam Tim could I reiterate
something that
your whole point about them ripping the
kids away from the parents that is the
entire point and you need to look no
further than their next steps that
they're already working towards right so
like uh the last year and a half two
years we've gotten 19 states to ban
these treatments and puberty blockers
for kids 19 right we need all 50 sex
changes child sex changes
where the blue states are going now
because they know the desistance rates
what they're doing is they're doing
trans trafficking bills right where
basically if the kid if you're on
vacation right and you're in um what
Washington State California or Minnesota
now and you are there and your kid calls
CPS or whatever calls the cops the state
can actually take your kids away from
you and put you in a foster it's worse
than that
your 13 year old kid is surfing on the
internet and goes on Tick Tock gets
exposed to the likes of Dylan Mulvaney
Dylan Mulvaney Advocates these children
drink alcohol haha it's so much fun
drink beer beer is fun
advocates for many of a lot of these
ideas kid gets confused
the kid says I can't talk to my parents
because people online are telling me
that my parents will get mad at me then
someone messages them and says if you
want I can drive you to Washington
stranger on the internet drives the kid
to Washington and says we saved them and
the state says yup you sure did
an internet stranger can kidnap your
child have them sterilized in another
state and that state says it's legal yep
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time